[Music]
hello everyone welcome thank you so much
for coming it's great to see you Full
House my name is Cameron Bailey I'm the
CEO of Tiff and I'm very glad that
you're all here media inclusion
initiative is to broaden and deepen the
perspectives on film that we get from
the critical Community it's not that any
one uh perspective is bad or wrong it's
that we need more of them we need more
perspectives and that's where you all
come in look forward to all of the
things that you're going to write and
publish and have seen and heard and I'm
so glad that my friend Jacqueline is
here to lead this panel please join me
in welcoming jacqulyn Coy from Rock
[Applause]
Tomatoes he has to leave because I don't
look that great up here so um thank you
so much Cameron sir um why don't I
without further Ado go ahead and welcome
up our panelists I'm jacqulyn Coley from
rotten tomatoes and thank you all so
much for being here let's go ahead and
bring our panelists up here we have KB
Eric Anderson and Esther
Zuckerman I also wanted to mention the
fact that we do have another panelist
who will literally be whisking
themselves into the airport as quickly
as they arrive so when Valerie complexes
arrives uh we will we will introduce her
as well I love seeing you all here
because everyone out there can
appreciate what it's like to be maybe at
your first film festival or maybe your
first International Film Festival and
you're like okay where do I go I see a
lot of badges so you guys got the first
big part done um but I love that this
panel is going to help all of you get
prepared to have a magical experience
which is one of the great sort of
bonuses of coming to a film festival and
seeing the art of moving Motion Pictures
as you can really make just kind of
incredible and intangible memories uh I
will start with ukb what brings you to
the festival and and I actually I think
I know your first you do cuz it was ours
it was what would you have wished we
would have known before that first time
that we know now after six more tips oh
my gosh that was such an incredible
experience because we were so green I
feel like I didn't know anything um but
I will say uh it has to do with red
carpets so I at the time when we got to
Tiff I had only done one red carpet ever
and it was a very small film in New York
City and the luxury of it which I didn't
realize was a luxury until I got to Tiff
was that every single outlet got every
single Talent yeah and that almost never
happens so I got to Tiff and you know
we're preparing for the red carpet we're
on the carpet you know they give us our
spots and we just had no idea that
Talent could just pass yes so you know
like my expectation was that all of the
talent was going to come that we were
going to get some of the the best
interviews and that just didn't happen
so I wish someone you know kind of would
have broken down uh the red carpet
structure and scene and how to kind of
create these Dynamic relationships with
the publicist beforehand and what it
also looked like to get one-on-one
interviews as opposed to the red carpet
um I wish I would have known that in
advance because I think it would have
been really really helpful yes but I'm
like but we had fun cuz we still got
good stuff we still we just had to be
very inventive we were the most friendly
people we were like hey come like it was
like you had to like make friends with
the publicist within 20 ft cuz she's
like standing in front of the other
interview and I'm like I'm going to make
you love me so by the time that you come
to this person you're going to like make
him stop or make them stop Esther what
do you wish you would have known before
because this is you've been doing this
for a while on both coasts multiple
Publications this is this is a lot yeah
I mean I first came in I think 2015 at
the time I was working for refiner 29
I'm currently freelance um covering for
a variety of different Publications here
like GQ and Vanity Fair and time
honestly the big thing was like making
time to eat that's so silly but just
like figuring out your schedule in a way
that's like healthy for you I think was
a huge thing um honestly like finding
Ravi Soup which is across the street and
like getting vegetables was a huge was a
huge thing um so I think it really was
like figuring out how to balance
schedules the other thing I also um
learned in that first time that I would
recommend is that you can like you can
make contacts with publist sort of and
get tickets to premieres you know I
think a lot of things are you know p&i
based you're going to the Press
screenings but you can be going to sort
of screenings at all hours of the day um
in any sort of form um so that is
something that I really you know wished
i' learned and sort of been prepped for
ahead of time You' sort of like learn on
the ground but everyone does that no
that makes really good sense and making
a grand entrance but
here everyone please welcome Valerie
complex our panelist joining us
freelancer
editor incredible writer sorry I
Wasing
late uh my flight was delayed for two
hours no this is great Val because this
is actually actually um one of the great
things most people need to know before
you come to a film festival and that is
travel issues whether you're riding up a
gondola to get to a film festival in the
mountains whether you're literally on a
boat like trying to get to a film
festival in Italy or whether you're just
trying to get from Pearson Airport to
King Street it's a struggle but no so
this is I'm literally not going to put
you on the spot this early but when I
come to you you I would love for you to
talk a little bit about how you roll
with travel and like get into things
because it's oh
absolutely because it's always something
it's always something um Eric I'm going
to bring it to you sir um first of all
tell us a little bit about your outlet
where you work and then what you wish
you would have known before your first
Tiff or for your before your first film
festival really sure uh my name is Eric
Anderson and I run a site called Awards
watch and I started it in
2013 it was initially a hobby because
all I wanted to do is talk about movies
and talk about the Oscars and and all of
that and then my husband gave me an
ultimatum of if you really want to do
this then you need to make a job out of
it because you're doing it for 14 hours
a day I said okay and the rest of that
was history and it um it took a lot of
years to kind of build a brand and build
uh a group of contributors including
Valerie who has written for me and it's
kind of kind of where it is now is is
much more than I expected it to be uh
it's it's kind of overwhelming it's
great um and it's one of those things
where I wish I had done it when I was
younger but at the same
time I think you don't have to put so
much pressure on yourself when you're
young to get to that point CU I'm
probably twice a lot of your ages and I
got there when I got there uh so things
can still work out uh
what did I wish I
knew before going to a festival I wish I
had gotten a whole lot more sleep when I
was younger to get caught up to the
sleep that I'm not going to have at a
film festival uh whether it's travel or
whether it's trying to watch uh a
holocaust movie at 8:00 in the morning
uh it's on a and a on a screen this big
you know it's yeah it's the funky thing
about festivals is each one of them is
different you're in different rooms with
different people and you just kind of
have to be able to Vibe with whatever
that screening is it might be totally
different than what you're used to and
yeah it might be in a room that feels
like a living room with a screen the
size of your TV or it might be at the
Scotia Bank with an IMAX uh of a type of
movie that you're not anticipating to be
on a screen like that so I
think I mean I'm a pretty open person
but I would as a piece of advice I would
say just be up absolutely completely
open to whatever the festival has to
offer you yeah that's an excellent point
um Val thank you so much for joining us
too what would you say is something that
folks should just be prepared for
because there are hiccups that happen
and there are things that
happen
um when it comes to travel it's really
important to Temp your expectations um
and to really probably have none and
kind of just go with it because
um you know I was expecting to be on
time today and look what happened so um
I think you know being able to it's not
that you can't be mad cuz of course I'm
like grumpy but I still you know realize
that these things happen and I'll
probably get over it once I have
something to eat so um I think you know
being completely like Eric mentioned
being open and being flexible to things
that might happen you could plan you
could do all the planning you want down
to the minute and something is going to
get up so I think that it's um
important to keep that in mind when
you're planning for things and you know
sometimes you may plan a schedule for
films and you got to miss one film to go
to the next or you may prefer to go to a
party that's happening at the same time
a movie you want to see but you know
somebody you want to meet is at the
party so you have to switch things
around or you know sometimes you might
go to the wrong movie theater sometimes
you might end up on the wrong Street
sometimes you'll get to the movie late
sometimes you won't make it at all and
sometimes the movie will be at 10:00 at
night and you'll be walking home alone
in can up the hill uh for a mile and a
half cuz no taxis are running and so um
you know it's just you got to it's all a
part of the experience um I guess it
would be if you do have one expectation
is to expect the unexpected no that's a
great one and those are the best
memories like coming home at 2: in the
morning like what what took you so long
to get here I got lost what took you so
long me and Val shared a room but no
what's really great about the network of
people that you have here are going to
be your network for as long as you're
doing this make friends here they're the
people you're going to room with when
you want to get to go to Venice when
it's really expensive like they're going
to be the ones that you're going to
share like a dorm style you know you
know hostile with so you can go so make
friends because 5 years later we're
still doing it and it's still part of I
wanted to like really quickly edify
y'all because Eric like him and jacqulyn
are the reasons why I was able to go to
can as a freelancer I wasn't attached to
any outlet and even though Eric was
pissed at me the whole time cuz I Wasing
up it was an it was an opportunity of a
lifetime I had so much fun and if it
wasn't for Jack on like hey I got to
play State and I've known Jaclyn KB for
I don't know six seven years whatever
and if it wasn't for that that wouldn't
have happened and I guess that's it yeah
no again relationships really matter
this is great that we're at Toronto
because it is such a festival where
there really is something for everyone
there's over 200 films programmed here
right now and just looking at the lineup
I've seen a few and I'm already like how
am I going to get everything that I want
to see packed into to the limited time
that I'm here and not have everyone back
there at Rotten Tomatoes fire view
because I stopped answering
emails it's a
balance I just have to answer like 10
emails and then I'll watch three movies
sorry guys no but it's a it's a it is a
balance because there's things you want
to do and people you want to network
with and lunch you want to go to parties
you want to go to so which films are you
making your Muses I'm going let everyone
know you can write read my Muses over at
Rotten tomatoes.com um there our must
watch for Tiff there's 11 selections um
I I will I just saw the Royal Hotel
Kitty greens movie uh this morning and
it was uh fabulous so um that was really
high in my list I'm obviously very
excited for tonight to see uh the boy
and the Heron um the Miaki film um I
actually you know a film that I already
saw it a prescreening that just wanted
to shout out cuz I really loved was his
three daughters as sasil Jacobs um film
um so yeah I mean in terms of how you
prioritize I think it is a mix like I
have a bunch of assignments for stuff
that I know I need to like hit um one of
them being Hitman the the Richard Ling
later movie um so it is a balance of
like what do I want to see what do I
have to see how do I sort of fit that
all in um you know the one thing I'd
recommend is like the another thing that
I I guess I wish I knew of my first tip
I find three movies a day to be the real
sweet spot
um I find if I do two a day that's like
feels like a little too little I find if
I do four a day it's like doable but my
brain starts to explode a little bit um
and I faint if I do five a day and then
I'm just like dead so that is one thing
that I would that that for me works I
think I've had this conversation with
Val a lot too it's okay to forgo a movie
if you know that you need to write like
I think that sometimes that's really
hard for us to accept but sometimes the
schedule just doesn't allow it and
sometimes you need an opportunity to
kind of sit down to write to prepare for
an interview or to just get your
thoughts out or even clean up your notes
because you know that you have a
deadline coming up so it's absolutely
okay to just forego that screening uh
see if there's a p&i at a later time uh
and then do that but I will say I I
agree to your point like I think three
to four movies a day is kind of my
personal sweet spot I think if I do four
it's fine you know just depending on
kind of what the times are uh because I
personally schedule in breaks to eat
because I know I will not survive this
Festival if I don't so I I create those
within my schedule and so if those four
kind of align with also the breaks to
make sure that I'm eating and that I'm
writing that I'm taking notes and that
you know I'm just taking a breather then
it works out interesting about that you
mentioned KB about saving time for
writing because that is a part of
balancing your schedule and and how you
do that um and as an editor I I
obviously have my expectations and needs
uh for the people that are writing for
me and I've definitely over the last
couple of years become a lot more
flexible and looser and less stringent
on my writers for this like 2hour
turnaround I mean
when I I don't know what Valerie was
expecting from me but I would I would be
you know we're across the world from
each other and I'd be like on video uh
Valerie where's that review what's going
on what's what what we what are we doing
here and I was I was much more um wait
an editor was waiting on a writer to
send copies shocking iing I tell you but
I but I was like you know I'm a small
Outlet I want to make sure that that you
know I can play with with the the big
players too and and and have things out
first and and a lot of times there's a
really great advantage of that if you're
a contributor and and you get to write
for an outlet letting your reviews out
there first and you get a pull quote
that is an huge thing for your career
visibility um but then over the years
and definitely the last couple of years
uh I've just loosened up a little bit
because it's not it's not going to get
me a better review and it's not going to
improve the writer to be under the wrong
kind of stress so uh I give yourself
time to write for sure but also
hopefully have a good editor that is is
workable okay so I was um a part of like
a while ago I was part of what we call a
second wave so the second wave was
basically a bunch of people who
published uh reviews the week after we
saw the movie um and it was because at
the time it was it's it takes so much
brain power for me to sit and like
organize my thoughts and put them in a
cohesive Manner and be able to explain
everything it just took so much time
that it took me like a week to like put
it together but now I work at deadline
which is um like a trade or whatever and
they wanted like right then and there
and I've learned you know how and even
you know in my time being there they've
loosened up as well because I'll tell
you a story when I started working for
deadline two years ago on September 1st
I got hired and then September 8th I was
at tiff with them and the very first
movie that I saw that I reviewed for
them out of a festival was called dear
Evan
Hansen yes and so um and so um they
wanted me to get it together right then
and there so as soon as I got out the
theater I had wrote a bunch of gibberish
and just published it they were like we
just want the by line out there cuz we
just want to be first we just want to be
first and I was apprehensive but I did
it anyway
and then I worked on the
review and then kind of got in trouble
for the review because it was very nasty
and um it wasn't it you can't be nasty
and in and and have grammar like that's
the problem like you have to be nasty
and sound like you put that stuff
through like Webster that's the problem
it was like you know and I had to keep
constantly going over it but it was I I
did not like that movie and it was clear
across the review and then people were
like well you know you should have you
know this and that I'm like what do you
expect when I haven't had time to think
about the film in a constructive way
you're getting my initial thoughts and I
was pissed off so that's what they
got and so yeah but that's a lesson for
setting a boundary that's a lesson for
like hey I bet you they never rushed you
after that no no um and it was like you
know they wanted me to see four films a
day and then put out the reviews like
afterward but I think they learned from
that and we've all learned from that
experience and so you know I get time to
think and publish a copy that is you
know worth reading it's about who you
know it's about having a relationship
that was a brand new publication you
didn't know anybody you didn't have
relationships with the staff really and
so you're learning on the Fly who do you
trust about this um also we've talked
about relationships in the sense of like
like we said if you're going to try to
come back to Tiff next year and you're
not part of the inclusion you know
there's real dollar that you have to put
down to be able to come back here and
your network is going to be your net
worth on that like how far can you go
who do you know so Eric I will say this
as an editor-in Chief you have to play
like a lot of both sides with it like it
literally is sometimes your writer where
you have the relationship with the
studio where you have a relationship
with I mean you are the business owner
talk about how you balance that with the
fairness but then also with the like hey
you know you can only do so
much uh on my tippy toes and the edge of
my fingernails every single day um yeah
it it is it is a balance because I I had
to learn how to be an editor just by by
doing it um and yeah those those
relationships every relationship that
you guys are going to have while you're
here uh is going to be really really
crucial like you said jacine next year
you know if you're not part of the the
inclusion initiative you have to figure
out
what what it is that you can bring to
Tiff that's going to have them say yes
to you uh so when you're in line you
know talk to people that are uh writing
for Outlets or a contributor and how how
their freelance experiences um Venice is
still going on I have six people there
uh editing and I'm editing like 25
reviews that happened on top of tell
ride uh which is is now overlapping into
here I even wrote two reviews myself and
I never ever ever write reviews anymore
uh it took me four days to write one of
the ones that you know so I have to be
also be really thoughtful
about not doing too much do as I say not
as I do that's not the type of editor
that I want to be I know it's one that I
have been before um so I have to be I
just have to be thoughtful um and and
and thoughtful to what
the what a writer needs because I am as
an editor there as their Mentor I am
there to help them to to make them a
better writer and make them more
confident that's maybe the the biggest
thing honestly more than anything is
that you know we can we can be editing a
piece together uh but it has to be a
balance
of constructive criticism as well as
here's instead of this word maybe maybe
this word or you know look look and see
that you've used this same word four
times what's another way you can say
that and and just presenting it in a way
that is I know you have it in you let's
let's figure out how to get there that's
fair Esther I mean anybody that
freelances to any degree and um will
understand this but as a freelancer it's
almost like I I hate to say it this way
but you're almost at the mercy of every
thing that you deal with whether it be
the studio is giving you access or the
editors hiring you for the job or vice
versa um how do you sort of make sure
that you're cultivating relationships
obviously authentically but just knowing
that like hey this is part of it as much
as it is making sure that I can write
well is making sure I know who these
people are that they know you know yeah
I mean I think everyone is here because
they love film um and I think you have
sort of think about that you know both
on the Publicis side and on the editor's
side and on the writer side and so I
sort of have cultivated a lot of
relationships you know with various um
people in all of those worlds mainly
just by talking about the films and
being honest um you know I'm not uh
saying I like something when I didn't
but um you know I think you'll find more
often than not everyone sort of just
wants to be honest and talk about their
films and you know chat about them um so
I think that's that is honestly the
biggest way is just the the love of film
that unites us it sounds so corny and
I'm really sorry about that but it is
like spending a lot of time you know
whether you're online at the Scotia Bank
or um you know at a party or you know
grabbing Robbie soups sorry I keep
talking about Robbie soups I really love
it um is uh you know
chat just chatting about the movies um
and you know what you thought about them
being you know being truthful like you
know another thing I'd say as someone I
freelan for a lot of different places um
and I've also worked been on staff at a
bunch of different places I've been on
staff at um thrillist and the a club and
ew and refiner as I mentioned and so I
think some of that is just um you know
reaching out to a lot of different
editors um and not sort of if if you're
pitching not sort of confining yourself
to one publication and sort of figuring
out what works for a specific
publication like what does like what
will that editor in particular respond
to I think a hard thing can be at a
festival is you know the Baseline is
like reviews like okay like yeah you go
see a movie you write a review but I
think there's like there are ways to
cover movies and there are ways to write
about movies that are not just that I
mean you know some of the stuff that I'm
writing here like for instance I'm I'm
writing some stuff for time um and that
stuff you know they they do reviews I
mean Stephanie after is one of my
favorite critics um and she's a fenice
um but she she handles reviews for them
so what I'm doing is a lot more of like
explainer explainer stuff sort of you
know based on the film and it's just
sort of a different way of looking at
film um you know you might highlight a
performance of a specific actor talk
about like how that functions in their
career you might sort of like pick out
like sometimes it's like as as like this
movie has like one crazy moment that
everyone's going to be talking about so
it's not so I think Thinking Beyond sort
of in terms of making connections with
editors um Thinking Beyond sometimes
like I want to write a view or I want to
interview a person like can be really
really helpful in terms of thinking how
to
pitch that's a really great advice um
this we're going to talk a little bit
about social media and this is going to
be so great cuz I love this KB I think
you're somebody that s sort of like is
obviously a film journalist but also
straddles that line you work with some
of these Brands how do you look at it as
you know I feel like every few years
I've seen this fight I saw this fight
when it was YouTube film people I saw
this fight when it was now Tik Tok film
people it seems like the fight is the
same every few years like it was even
the fight with like movie podcast people
for a while like is that film criticism
and then Katrina Longwell came along and
they're like well maybe it is so yeah
how do how do you feel you can do the
balance now between the social media
film criticism and more traditional how
can we marry it what's the future for
audiences you know that's actually a
really good question I don't have Tik
Tok or I do but I don't use it so I
guess I don't I don't really I don't
really know how to say it but um I don't
really use Tik Tok but I do agree that
like over the course of probably 10
years we have done a lot of the same
conversation and so as someone who has
done a film criticism podcast like I've
hosted one I've had other Critics on to
chat about it we've talked about you
know major films at a lot of different
festivals um it was just really for me
and I can only speak for myself another
platform to get my voice and my content
out it was great to just be able to talk
to a group of other critics freely and
review the film from top to bottom talk
about all the things we hate all the
things we love so you know um as someone
who started off writing reviews and
doing it in the traditional the quote
unquote I guess traditional capacity I
didn't find working as a podcaster and
doing criticism in that particular
medium to be any less valuable I mean
you know like we were the same people
the people that I had on my show were
the same people that you know I'd
written reviews with at the same Outlet
so you know our our thought pattern our
process it was just more of a I don't
know how do I say this like a community
feel it was more of a comaraderie in
that particular space and so even when
it comes to YouTube reviews like I feel
like it's very similar in the sense that
you know it's an opportunity to still be
able to get your thoughts out about this
body of work that you were either super
excited to see or you just wanted to
hate watch right like you know there's
an opportunity for both so I think when
it comes to social media and the
evolution listen I will be the first to
say that like um Facebook when Facebook
first came out I was one of the first
like 10 universities so I've seen kind
of this Evolution you know from Facebook
to meta and how YouTube has grown and so
things are shifting things are changing
and so to your point I mean there are a
lot of ticktockers that I find to be
actual filmmakers like they're really
good and I don't edit and they do and I
don't know how they do it and that's
probably why I don't use Tik Tok because
you know it's just just not really my
wheelhouse but it is evolving and so I
don't know I I I find that we just have
to kind of take a seat and see where the
evolution of social media may lead us um
you know because if people are doing you
know a five minute Tik Tok review of a
film I don't know like who am I to say
that that is not necessarily valid when
we all started in a form and and then it
became you know kind of accepted
socially so like me being a podcast host
wasn't to your point necessarily
accepted in the beginning now it is me
being on YouTube was it necessarily now
it is so you know things are evolving
kind of at a rapid pace and so I
personally am not the one to judge but I
do think that there are a lot of
creative people in the universe and I
find that my favorite thing about film
criticism is the fact that we have
varying opinions I want to hear
someone's like make tell me why you love
this film that I hate so much I actually
would love to hear another take of about
it because while I still hate it I
appreciate your Viewpoint and your
perspective on letting me know what it
is yeah I think the main thing with it
is that and I'm like let me not get too
Elder Millennial in this as I say this
but just it's it's weird when like you
separate Somebody by five years in a
platform and they think that the
previous ones are the enemy I'm like we
are the same like like you me same just
we do skinny jeans y'all do straight leg
it's not that big a difference it's sort
of you know I mean so that's the only
thing I would say is like maybe don't
like hate on your like previous versions
because in the end we are all
frantically praying that the movie
industry as a whole is booed through the
next Century because it is under threat
so like maybe don't fight the other kids
in the house I don't know that is me
yeah because at at the beginning of all
of this you know what it took to be a
film critic there was it's a tiny number
it was newspapers and radio
and television
and you could count on two hands how
many of those people had jobs it was a
really really small number of people and
you know they were majority white men
and as the evolution of not just
criticism but clearly internet and
opportunity has grown uh that's that's
the the the true openness of of those
voices so you can fight against every
new iteration that that comes along um
but I don't think it's really going to
get you very far I think that my my
thing is
like people are starting to use movie
reviewer and journalists interchangeably
and they're not the same or critic and
it's not the same there's tons of movie
reviewers and people that I want to hear
from are they journalists I don't know
yeah um it's looking like no but um you
know some are and some you know are not
uh I think that's where the contention
is for me um you want to talk about all
the Marvel movies I don't care but when
we started talking about journalism it's
like I don't you know I don't know some
people do video essays and stuff like
that and I think that that's really
creative and you know movie video essay
is they all have their own name um label
and I'm not trying to like gatekeep
labels and stuff like that but I think
there's a little bit of a the the line
is too thin there um and I think it
needs to be differentiated really
quickly how I got the job at deadline
was actually one of the producers of the
um what was that movie with Olivia
Coleman and Dakota uh oh lost daughter
the Lost daughter one of the producers
of the Lost daughter reached out to me
and was like they're hiring I was like I
don't know you who are you and she was
like oh you know I follow your work and
everything and I love it and I think
you'd be a great voice it's another
important component find your own voice
and make it as strong as possible try to
stand out amongst you know each other
and have a niche that you sort of focus
on the other thing about networking is
have a place where people can find you
if you're not on social
media I don't know what to tell you
because I you know I think I think you
may not be into using social media but
you need to have a place where somebody
can find you whether it's a website um
or it's your Instagram or Twitter
whatever I I you just have to and also
networking is important if you're shy
like look I'm an introvert I like to be
in the house eating and minding my
business under the AC but you know I
come to these events and I get on the on
the grind cuz there's contacts to be
made there's you know there's
connections to be had one opportunity of
meeting someone could send you to the
other side of the world um as as a jury
person or something like that absolutely
true because I think everybody when you
come to these events wants to like find
the executive EVP everybody wants to go
find the boss you want to go find the
editor and chief the hiring manager
that's dope definitely have those people
know you but the guy who can edit on
Premiere that is standing next to you in
line at the Scotia Bank is way more
valuable than the person that's the CEO
you are four jobs away from that CEO
being able to offer you a job that they
connect to you know what I mean but that
kid may be a PA on a movie in 3 years
that you may be a script supervisor on
because you remembered that you like
scripts and he likes Premiere so that is
a that's the one thing I would say is
Network sideways more than you network
up yeah I was going to actually say that
Network across because you know I have
found to your point with the evolution
of kind of social media and this film
criticism space I will say a lot of us
created these opportunities because we
weren't getting staffed because we
weren't getting writing jobs and so it's
real hard y'all to be black and a woman
in this industry and a lot of other
things queer it's it's just hard in
general for a lot of marginalized
communities and to be able to get staff
writing jobs that's just a fact like it
pretty much almost doesn't happen and I
can say that as someone here who has
never been staffed I have never been
staffed by an outlet I've only been
freelance and so a lot of that has been
because I just Network across you know
like I have to shout out you know like
shironda Williams at payer weight I have
to shout out theres Laxon I have to
shout out Heidi Mcdonald I mean these
three women when I wanted to do
something different within the industry
allowed me the space and the opportunity
to be able to create on their platforms
and to be able to do certain things and
we were able to change the dynamic so
you know creating kind of these YouTube
channels creating these podcasts are
direct result of you know kind of
networking across and I have to say I
hosted season two of the color grade
podcast which was a film criticism
podcast um you know I hosted that
because of Joy child because she worked
with us at that outlet that we all
started with and she had to you know
give up her spot as host of season one
and so for season two she was like oh I
want you to do it and so she recommend
ended me so again I think networking you
know like I'm sitting up here now
because of jacn that was a Spotify
podcast that was like part of their
Network and their like when they did all
their new podcasts and everything so
it's just it's it's one of those things
where you know you guys are absolutely
right we have to network across because
you know just like Val said you know
Eric and Jacqueline really helped her
when it came to um you know can and
going to that film festival we can
always help each other I think that that
is kind of the beauty of this community
is us looking to each other to be able
to help and like y'all I'm going to say
it cuz no one
has but share contacts so like I mean
you know like that's the way to build
relationships is sharing contacts it's
the only way that we can do it you know
you absolutely obviously like once you
get that contact it's on you to be able
to kind of build that professional
relationship from there but just having
the opportunity to just say actually hey
I would like to talk the publicist about
this film do you happen to have their
information sure I'm happy to do an
email introduction so that way you two
can connect about this film that you
really want to see and you know let you
take it from there so yeah we're going
to have to turn it over to the audience
now for a couple of questions um right
here yes hi Callum rudik citr and
Discord or magazine H I've always wanted
to do
that I wanted to thank you first for
your fantastic answers this has been
really informative and a great way to
start the festival off and Esther and
Val you both touched a bit on the need
to adjust somebody's schedule on the Fly
and the need sometimes to you know not
go to a certain screening in favor of a
party or a chance to meet somebody uh
and in you know the leadup to the
festival we've been told all the time
like you should really make a schedule
and stick to it or else you might have
consequences in the future um do you
have any more advice on maintaining
specifically good relationships with
like scheduling people and
so that you don't get penalized for
sometimes needing to you know Miss
something that you said you would go to
or you know that sort of thing I mean
honestly like I think I I I'm not sure
what how you guys like manage your
schedules and anything like that but I
always think like you know people at
festivals understand that it's a crazy
crazy time so just like be polite be
like um and like you know explain your
situation and I think people typically
would be fine with it um everyone know
everyone here whether you're a
journalist or you know an official or
you know a publicist is also adjusting
on the Fly everything is happening like
you know I heard of a press screening
this morning of a movie that's really
good sleep it's a Korean horror film um
it's really great I heard that something
went wrong at a scoa bank this morning
and like their p and has to be
rescheduled like
from the publicist working out so it's
like everything everything EV everyone
is dealing with this so no that b
anything you want to add um I have I
keep a schedule but um sometimes I just
switch things around I think it's
important to be honest with the people
that you may be reporting to and being
like um you know if you know as far in
advance as you can like hey I am not
going to make this screening for this
reason or or if you're burnt out tell
them you're burnt out um just be as
honest as possible and if the if you're
working for the type of people who are
not as understanding maybe that's not
the place for you um you know you want
to make sure that your goals and your
boundaries are able to align with the
people that you're working with um I
think that's the most important thing
thank you so much hi my name is Ruby
Raven I'm also with discorder magazine
in citr radio uh thank you so much for
talking to us today I already feel like
I've learned a ton and a lot of my
initial questions have been answered um
my question is for KB and Eric I was
just wondering if you guys could talk a
little bit more about the
entrepreneurial nature of how your
careers got started because it sounds
like you didn't go through those
traditional routes to get where you are
today sort of along the lines of the
last question uh answer every single
email even if it's a polite pass if you
can answer every publicist because that
response is still relationship building
and if you ignore it then at some point
they're just going to stop messaging you
and you know you might miss out on
something that you do want to do uh but
but having that that polite interaction
uh will keep them coming back and you
know I I started just in like Movie
Forums and in the beginning early days
of the internet of just talking about
movies so I didn't have any real
connection at that point um but then I
did find a few people that were very
willing uh to not gatekeep uh
contacts uh and that was that was
everything that mattered because you
know you can pay for IMDb Pro uh and get
agent publicist uh emails and all of
that stuff and I still use that now if I
don't have that contact I go right there
and that's where I start but at the very
beginning it is relationship building it
is making sure that the people that are
in line with you are
potentially uh connections and and and
that
was that was everything for me um
and something I I I want to say to
everybody here as well though is I think
a lot of times in this industry
regardless of what we're doing there is
a certain level of impostor syndrome
that we can put on ourselves like we
don't deserve to be here or what am I
doing here I think there's it's good to
have a little bit about that of impostor
syndrome that kind of keeps you uh
grounded but I'll say to everybody
here you you already got here you are
here so you've already made such a huge
leap in whatever it is that you want to
do
that you're you're already there uh and
you should be really just proud of
yourselves for being a part of this
today because it's going to build the
next thing that you do um and I'm always
really open so you can always message me
I love taking on anybody and working
with anybody
um vals talked a little bit about the
can thing that was a an Absol abute like
life-changing moment for me in how I
viewed what my site could do and what I
could do I had gone to the cam film
festival in
2018 uh as press for the first time
myself there were 4,000 journalists
there were two black women the of the
entire lineup and that shook me I could
not it it didn't make sense I was being
really naive but it didn't make any
sense and so the next year I gave Val m
my uh uh
accreditation and I realized in that
moment that that was my power and I
could either hold it or I could help and
from that point on that's sort of been
like my thing is is trying to give voice
and and
opportunity again find somebody who is
willing to not gatekeep those
opportunities for themselves and willing
and open to give them to other people
last question right here hello I'm
Edward fumkin freelance ran for freeze
in new wire and other places my question
is how do you make a good pitch of an
event or movie you want to write to an
editor but you don't have access to the
movie with the pr list or Studios and
also how do you make it as good as
possible without relying the pr
releases yeah so how do you make a
killer pitch I think Val you can answer
this one too cuz you did also like
several years as a freelancer and you
still now have to deal with Freelancers
in your current role
[Music]
um I looked up formats online I'm I'm I
I have like ADHD and um
formats help like the structure helped
me so I looked online and was like okay
so where does what information go to go
into and then I would write that up and
then I would send it off to uh maybe
someone like Eric or someone like KB or
Jack like how does this read um I would
have someone look over it and then I
would send the pitch out um no matter
how sometimes no matter how good your
pitch is they still going to say no so I
think um be aware of that and be okay
with that it doesn't have anything to do
with you or the style of your work or
your writing is just may not be what
they're looking for at at that moment
but um I try to keep my pictures short
very like three or four very small
paragraphs this is who I am this is what
I can bring to the table you know this
is this here's the pitch and you know
how much you want to get paid how much
you want to get paid and you know how it
will add to the to the current um outlet
that you're at thank you very much also
I will shout out our Rotten Tomatoes
critics lab up on our site we have how
to pitch Sophie Jenny Eric that's why I
didn't call on you Eric cuz you're were
a part of that lab they talk about how
to pitch for both film festivals and for
regular assignments and that is a great
resource for both critics and people
that are not critics it's just up on our
site as well as several BIOS with a lot
of the folks here where you can get to
know your critic that is going to be all
for us can something really really fast
no really really fast I want um as you
get into this industry don't be afraid
to speak out against Injustice if you
see something um say something you know
you don't have to be crazy or whatever
like I was
but it is another way to make yourself
known not as the enemy but of as of
someone who is honest and who will call
out the injustices they see I sat down
with KB and a couple of other black
critics in 2018 at Sundance and we
actually talked about how can we get
people of color to some of these uh film
festivals
the media initiatives that exist came
out of that discussion that happened at
a Chinese restaurant with the nastiest
food I had had at Sundance with people
who I can with people who I made
connections with so I want you all to
know that this is the kind of change
that you can have that's your power as
Eric was talking about um to you know to
affect change so I just want to say that
yeah we they that table happened and
then we infected to the various prongs I
brought it to Rotten Tomatoes other
people yeah I was say I remember you too
it's no but then you talked to deadline
like all the Publications that we've
worked at have all submitted funds to
these initiatives and it was not by
accident it was by Design so yes again
she's right that's that's worth that's
worth the extra minute thank you they
keep a tight ship here at Tiff though so
we are going to call it now I want to
thank all of you for watching thank all
of our panelists thanks for having
me
[Music]
than